let's talk about some really interesting
and odd details in Celebrity marital
prenups so reportedly when Jessica
Simpson and Tony Romo were engaged they
signed a prenup that said she couldn't
weigh more than 135 pounds and the
prenup also required her to pay him half
a million dollars for every pound that
she gained but they didn't even end up
getting married they broke up in 2009
and I'm sure we can all agree that was
for the best okay now let me tell you
what Chloe and Lamar's prenup said the
prenup reportedly entitled her to a new
car every time her lease was up
Courtside Laker tickets for her entire
family a five thousand dollar monthly
allowance for shopping a one thousand
dollar monthly allowance for beauty
expenses twenty five thousand in monthly
spousal support and 500 000 for every
year of marriage iced tea and Coco
Austin reportedly signed a prenup that
says that she has to return her breast
implants and her butt implants to him if
they ever get divorced don't know what
he would do with those but okay
unreportedly Justin Timberlake and
Jessica Beals bring up says that if he
ever cheats on her she gets half a
million dollars